we're given that the definite integral
from one to four of f of X DX is equal
to 6 and the definite integral from 1 to
7 of f of X DX is equal to 11 and we
want to figure out the definite integral
from 4 to 7 of f of X DX so at least in
my brain I'm visualizing these as areas
between the curve y equals f of X and
the x-axis and so let's just draw that
we don't know exactly what f of X is but
we can draw an arbitrary f of X just to
help us visualize things so let me draw
so if that is drive it in a bolder color
so that's our y-axis and this is our
x-axis and let's see all the action is
happening between X from X is going from
1 to 7 so we could go 1 I mean we can go
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 and we can even go to 8 if
we like but the important numbers see
we're dealing with 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 and
then we go to 8 and let me just draw the
graph y equals f of X and I'm just going
to draw something arbitrary here so
let's say the graph of y equals f of X
looks like that
y is equal to f of X of course I let me
label my axes that's the x axis that is
the y axis now let's think about what
each of these integrals represent so the
integral the definite integral from 1 to
4 well that's going to be we're going to
be going from 1 to 4 right over here so
this is the definite integral from 1 to
4 this area in under the curve between
the curve and the x-axis DX which is
equal to 6 and now let's see we also
have the region that goes from from 4 to
7 we have this region right over here
and that that area is represented by
this definite integral the one that we
need to figure out the definite integral
from 4 to 7 of f of X DX we need to
figure that out
and they also what else do we have so
let me underline this so that's that
this is the area of the region between x
equals 4 and x equals 7 under y equals f
of X above the x-axis and then they also
gave us this last piece of information
which is let me do this in another color
the definite integral from 1 to 7 well
that's going from 1 1 all the way to 7
so that's the sum of these two regions
right over here so we could rewrite this
as the definite integral from 1 to 4 of
f of X DX plus plus the definite
integral from 4 to 7 of f of X DX is
equal to is equal to the definite
integral from 1 to 7 1 to 7 of f of X DX
and notice what's going on here this the
first one just goes to the area from 1
to 4 then we go from 4 to 7 so if you
add those together that's going to be
the area from 1 to 7 from 1 to 7 and so
they give us a lot of this information
they tell us that this right over here
is 6 let me do that same color they tell
us that this is 6 they tell us that this
is 11 and so we have 6 plus this is
equal to 11 well 6 plus what is equal to
11 well this thing right over here must
be equal to this thing right the the
definite integral from 4 to 7 must be
equal to 5 this must be equal to 5
another way to think about it if this
region right over I'm having trouble
switching colors if this region right
over here is 6 so that has an area of 6
and the whole region if everything has
an area of 11 so if that Plus that has
an area of 11 well then the stuff that
we don't know this orange this orange
region this orange region is going to be
11
- six so this region right over here is
going to have an area of five